[موسيقى]
لايبيريا اول وبلد الافريقيا يحصلوا على
استقلاله الا انه مجمل تاريخه يعد فريدا
في القريه السمراء احتفلت تليبيريا في عام
2022 بمرور 200 عاما على تاسيسها كان ذلك
على ايدي جمعيه امريكيه قامت بتمويل وشراء
هذه الاراضي لتوصيل نحو 30 الف من العبيد
المحررين عبروا المحيط الاطلنتي للعيش على
السواحل الغربيه الافريقيه اسسوا مدينه من
روسيا التي اصبحت عاصمه ليبيريا وسميت
بهذا الاسم تكريما للرئيس الامريكي الخامس
جيمس مونوي اصبحت ليبيريا اذن رسميا
جمهوريه مستقله في عام
1847 الا انها العبيد المحررين امسكوا
بسمام الحكم وحلو محل السكان الاصليين
الذين اصبحوا مواطنين من الدرجه الثانيه
لم يحصلوا على الحق في التصويت الا بعد
مروري مئتي عام استمر العداء بين سكان
الاصليين وابناء المتحدرين من القاره
الامريكيه لفتره طويله في عام
1980 اعتلى السلطه للمره الاولى واحد من
السكان الاصليين ساموال دواء عقبا انقلاب
لتشهد البلاد حروب الاهليه خلال عقدين او
قاعات اكثر من 250,000 قتيله عدا السلام
الى ليبيريا في عام 2003 ولكن وبالرغم من
ثرواتها الطبيعيه الضخمه الا انها ما زالت
من بين ال 20 بلدا الاقل تطورا في العالم
عدد كبير من الامريكيين من اصول افريقيه
ينبهر
ويقرروا السفر اليها والعيش فيها مع ذلك
يعتبر والكثيرون ان البلاد وبالرغم من
مرور مئتي عاما على تاسيسها الا انها ما
زالت تحمل اثاره جراح الحروب الاهليه
وجرائم بدون عقاب تذكره عوده الى ليبيريا
[تصفيق]
هذا العام تحتفل ليبيريا بذكرى مرور 100
عام على اعلان استقلالها
فيما لم يمضي على استقلال الجيرانها في
القاره سوى 60 عاما
العيد هو العوده الكبرى للامريكيين لذوي
الاصول الافريقيه الى اوطانهم الافريقيه
وهذا ما يعتبره الرئيس جورج ويايا مفخره
القادمه دعونا نفكر فيما وراء هذا العيد
في الجيل الذي سيخلفنا في سنوات القادمه
وفي الايام الجميله التي ستاتي وفي كيف
سنمهد الطريق كي يكون مستقبلهم افضل من
مستقبلينا وفرصهم احسن من فرصنا ونموهم
وتطورهم افضل منه
[تصفيق]
تحتفل اليوم بذكرى تاسيسها المئتين فلان
تاريخ هذا البلد الصغير الواقع شرق
افريقيا غير عادي ففي
1822 استقبل البلد العبيد المحررين
وابنائهم القادمين من امريكا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
السفن على هذه الجزيره كان هؤلاء الرجال
والنساء والاطفال المحررون على موعد مع
حياه جديده
حياه بعيده عن الاستعداد لدرجه التغيير
اسم البلد ليصبح لبيريا او ارض الحريه
اليزابيث ابنه البلاد وتعيش في الولايات
المتحده
وبهذه المناسبه قررت العوده على خطى
الاجداد
الاول كان من الاف العبيد المحررين الذين
قدموا الى جزيره
بروفيدانسهم
القرارات الشخصيه وغير ذلك
[موسيقى]
اليزابيث واحده من من ولد من ابن امريكي
ليبيري وام ليبيري
جيل كبرى وبات يرى ان استحضار ماضي
الاجداد يذكر بفتره العبوديه الاليمه
[موسيقى]
لم يركب جميع العبيد المحررين تلك السفن
بملئ ارادتهم
منهم من رحلته جمعيه الاستعمار الامريكيه
بالقوه وهي جمعيه من الامريكيين البيض
بعضهم يؤيد حظر العبوديه وبعضهم ضد فكره
التعايش مع العبيد المحررين
على النموذج الامريكي الذي يعرفونه بدا
ببناء الكنائس احدهم بنى فورا وصوله هذه
الكنيسه
القصدير هو راعي هذه الكنيسه منذ عده
سنوات
[تصفيق]
الذين سيعيشون هنا يعتنقون الدين المسيحي
هذا من اسباب تاسيس ليبيريا لجلب المسيحيه
والحضاره لهذا الجزء من العالم
[تصفيق]
ادي له ركيزه اساسيه في تاسيس ليبيريا
وركيزه ايضا في الحياه السياسيه في البلاد
ففي هذه الكنيسه تم توقيع اعلان الاستقلال
عام
واصبحت ليبيريا اول بلد في القاره
الافريقيه يتحرك
القصص ديك يرى ان هذا الحدث الهام كان
بدايته هيمنه الامريكيين الليبيرين على
السكان الاصليين
الدفاع عن القدس الافارقه
طبيعيه
اذن حتى لو عدنا الى الانتقال من جزيره
بروفي دانس الى حيث نحن فقد استخدم السلاح
لجعل السكان الاصليين يتخلون لهم عن بعض
الاراضي ويخضعون لهم
الامريكيون الليبيريون الملقبون ايضا
بقوميه الكونغو ارتقوا الى اعلى الهرم
الاجتماعي مع حزبهم السياسي حزب ترويج
تولوا اداره البلد لاكثر من قرن هذه
البنايه المطله على العاصمه كانت مقرهم
واليوم لم تبقى سوى الاطلال شاهده على
حقبه خلف
[موسيقى]
القرارات في الماضي
حسن بيلتي صحفي سابق وهو اليوم ناشط
ويرانا من المهم هدم الاساطير التي تكتنف
بدايه التاريخ الليبيري
ا لم تستعمر لكن هذا غير صحيح لقد
استعمرتها منظمه الغير حكوميه وسيطرت على
السكان الاصليين
لكن الكراهيه والغضب عداليا فجر في
السبعينات
[موسيقى]
عام 1980
وكان عام
1980 منعطفا تاريخيا في ليبيري سامويل دو
اخذ الحكم بالقوه واصبح اول رئيس للبلاد
من السكان الاصليين وبذلك سار الاصليون من
الوافدين حكم تبعه مره اخرى العنف والفساد
وبعد 10 سنوات جاءت تشارلز ستيلر ذو الابل
الامريكي ليبيري والام المنحدره من السكان
الاصليين ليجتاح البلد من كوت ديفوار
ويطيح بسموالدو فاندلعت الحرب الاهليه في
ليبيريا التي سقط فيها اكثر من
20000 قتيل بين
1989 و 2003
حسن بيليتيج على من تتبع مجرمي الحرب
وظيفته وقد اسس البرنامج العالمي للعداله
والابحاث وهو جمعيه يوثق معها مختلف
المجازر التي طبعت تاريخ البلد
السابق بمفوضيه الحقيقه والمصالحه من اجل
وضع حد للافلات من العقاب لانه الى حد
اليوم لم يحاكم اي مجرم حرب امام القضاء
الليبيري
في ليبيريا
من العقاب موجود بقوه
[موسيقى]
هذا ليس نتيجه الحرب فقط
وتراث منذ تاسيس الجمهوريه
لما كان لدينا فساد غياب العداله جعل
الناس يفعلون ما يحلو لهم وفي كل مره
ينجون بافعالهم
يناضل خاصه من اجل الناجين من المجازر في
كنيسه سنه بيتر في منوفيه
هذه كنيسه الاثريه تقع في شارع الرئيسي من
روسيا
هنا
الحرب الاهليه
1990 اطلق جنود القوات المسلحه
عليها اثار الرصاص بعد ثلاثين عاما
الكنيسه اعاده فتح بابها لكن بعض الناجين
لن يستطيعوا ابدا ارتيادها للصلاه
فهم يعيشون معزولين في قرى يصعب الوصول
اليها
وبعدهم لا يقوى على المشي ولا على العمل
[موسيقى]
نجا من الاعتداء على كنيسه سان بيتر لانه
تظاهر بالموت
ريه مع ابن الصغير
[موسيقى]
وصفات الناس تبعوا للهرب تحت الرصاص
وسقطوا طباعا فوق بعضهم البعض
جسديه وكذلك نفسيا
على مقتل ابنه في عامين واخته في تلك
الليله
في الكنيسه صعد بعض العناصر للطابق العلوي
لقتل النساء
الى ان تاكدوا من موت الجميع
صدمات مؤلمه بات على ريفيوس معايشتها كل
يوم
الحكومه لا تفعل شيئا للنجم لذلك يعتمد
كثير منهم على ناشطين كابيتر سنسونيا في
العلاج والمعيشه
[موسيقى]
ما كان يمكن تفادي ماساه ليبيريا في بلد
تاسس على الانقسامات كثير من المؤرخين
يرون ان الحروب الاهليه سببها التوترات
بين سكان الاصليين وقوميه الكونغو الوافده
لكن هذا الناشط الذي يناضل من اجل الضحايا
يرى ان هذا النقاش لم يعد موضوع الساعه
كنا نستطيع معرفه منهم من قوميه الكونغو
ومن ولده هنا
كل شيء في البلد
الاجحافات الاجتماعيه التي عرفها المجتمع
لريف الماضي جعلته منخورا بالفساد والعنف
والفقر المدفع
ليبيريا تندرج ضمن افقر عشر دول في العالم
[موسيقى]
الذي كان منذ 200 عام
نموذجيه والتنميه في افريقيا
اليوم يصلي الشباب كي تستعد لبريال
كرامتها وعظمته
[موسيقى]
الى الهاتف